Chúc quan ngày 28 tháng 10 năm 2020, công an tình còn chỉ đã ra quy định khởi tố vua an giết người và khức tài sản xe ra tại phương đúng sân,
còn chỉ đồng thời tạm giữa hình sự mến và giống, sinh năm 2020 trình xong triên 12,
chú phần đúng sân để tiếp tục đúng ra làm só.
Được ra ban đầu trong các ngày 29, 2020 tháng 10 năm 2020,
giống đám mạng để thoại và xe máy để cầm của tạng nhà bà tế tế tế, sinh năm 2020,
chú phần đúng sân để vai tình yêu sài, sau khi sự giống thế số tiền này,
giống thế tục lấy trụ mi tám phy nâm sự đồng của mẹ dụt, khi bị ra đình phát hiện, giống ngày xin ý định cứ tài sản địa có tiền trả lại.
Hòa 18, 2020 tháng 20 năm 2020, giống mạng theo phục ký đến nhà bà tế,
nó chả nửa vở yếu cầu bà đưa thiên mì sự đồng, nửa sẽ chuyển khoảng trả lại sau.
Tại phong khác, khi bà tế đưa dưới tờ công cố cùng tiền, giống đá dùng vụ ký không xế bà tế dồi tình công đến tức kính là nhân từ bó ký được lưu đi cấp cứu,
khoảng hai dờ sau lực lượng công an bát được súng của khí tế an.